welcome back to the show that today will
showcase a diabolical director dyad
two of the all-time horror masters will
go mono amano for eternal scary cinema
supremacy
who am i i'm not jack burton i'm mark
just a person like you who has had many
a sleepless night at the hands of these
creative geniuses
john carpenter and wes craven or as
tatum from scream more succinctly put it
duck others said you're starting to
sound like some west carpenter
john carpenter he of the halloween and
escape from coastal cities flicks
is world renowned for giving us chills
accentuated by his own
abilities as a musician wes craven
gained a worldwide fan base thanks to
franchises like a nightmare in elm
street and scream
together the fellows forged a close
friendship up until wes craven's passing
likely out of necessity as they had
probably already scared the crap out of
the rest of their friends
hey you want to come down to the set and
look at dailies nope
why not because your movies have turned
me into a bedwetter
is that just that's just me i mean i was
i was acting
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
round three iconic moments and then i'll
do a wild card round that i hope is less
exhausting than that fight scene from
they live
i got my own rowdy roddy piper bubblegum
soda
and the people under the stairs have
promised to remain quiet for 20 minutes
so let's get it on there are certain
rules
that one must abide by in order to
successfully survive a horror movie
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding
round one box office horror movies are
best viewed in large groups of people
sure you can toss on a few scary flicks
at home by yourself but when it's made
by a true master of the genre
time to gas up to jalopy get a ticket
put some sour patch
kids in the popcorn and join an army of
fellow bed wet shriekers
shriekers
john carpenter not only revolutionized
the slasher picture with his original
halloween but he did so
using the change you find in between the
couch cushions made on a budget of just
325 thousand dollars
okay so maybe the couch had rich parents
1978's halloween would go on to gross
188 million dollars
he'd follow that up with a 74 million
grossing the fog
and then escaped from new york which
raked in 85 million bucks
and although his more recent films like
village of the damned and ghosts of mars
haven't been boxed off as juggernuts
he was instrumental in david gordon
green's 2018
halloween reboot cool seeing the light
of day
and that cashed its chip to the tune of
165 million dollars domestically
all told john has directed 15 flicks
that have made a total of 800 million
dollars
if we focus on his horror thriller
i don't know how to say that word it's
10 movies that have pulled in 524
million dollars
making for a healthy average of you can
do this one eighth graders
52.4 million dollars well done
now have fun trick-or-treating if you
keep doing it in high school it's kind
of weird
speaking of high scores remember those
silly kids from woodsboro
yeah it turns out they weren't real but
another sterling creation directed by
wes craven from the mind of kevin
williamson
before he made a mint torturing poor
sydney prescott craven kicked off his
directorial career
with the film every horror lover dares
you to see
last house on the left and although that
grossed just 17 million dollars
craven followed up with 1976's the hills
have eyes
and 1984's debut of some glove-wearing
whack job
in a nightmare on elm street elm street
earned 68 million dollars and should
probably get credit for a sales spike in
caffeinated beverages
ah you can't get me if i'm awake freddie
craven almost exclusively stuck to the
horror genre
and his total numbers are staggering 17
movies
1.23 billion dollars at the box office
and if you think poor john carpenter
just hasn't had as many swings at the
freight plate as west
consider this wes's average film pulled
in 72 million dollars
easily besting john's statistic in that
category
for funsies let's combine their movies
and see what the top five looks like
uh it's scary very very
scary and it's four west craven movies
scream is number one overall with 211
million
scream two and three are in the top five
as well sandwiching michael myers
rookie outing in halloween that sandwich
should
not be eaten nope put that in a case
next to annabelle in the warren's
cursed artifact room what'd you say wes
craven gets the win in round one and
takes a one-nothing lead over john
carpenter
don't [ __ ] with the original round two
tomato meter slash
audience score every audience loves
going to see a horror flick opening
weekend
the theater is packed it's dark no one's
on their phone
right but after the screams died down
and the lights come up
how does the crowd feel about it then
hot off his round one win
wes craven scores another big punch with
his audience scored digits
his scary flicks averaged 47 percent
which is rotten but for a guy who made
horror movies
that's impressive his percentage is
buoyed by fan favorites
nightmare on elm street at 83 percent
scream at 79 percent
and new nightmare is 66 high profile
projects scream 3 and vampire and
brooklyn are both in the 30 percentile
but i think we can all agree
it was worth it to see eddie murphy as a
vampire right
anyone bueller where did you get that
this huh that's from bloomingdale's i
kicked in the window and took it off on
the little white man against you
craven's tomato meter is almost a mirror
image of his audience score just
slightly better looking at 48
his greatest hits get even mightier as
evidenced by the original nightmare
getting an
a at 94 percent meanwhile vampire in
brooklyn
clearly didn't study and wound up with a
woeful 10
next time
put a little heart into it horror movies
don't always hit with critics so while
wes is giving it a good go in round two
the door is open for john carpenter to
tie things up
and he comes out swinging with haymakers
like halloween at 96 percent on the
tomato meter
assault on precinct 13 the 1970s
original
at 98 percent and they live at 86
percent
even scary misfires like the ward at 33
percent
and vampires at 40 percent can only
weigh down his average to a still fresh
60 for his horror movies and 67 percent
for his overall catalog
getting back to vampires we did get to
see jon bon jovi in that
which begs the question can we do an
eddie murphy versus bon jovi versus
episode
come on the people deserve to know is
beverly hills cop
better than slippery when
did you wet that one carpenter's
audience score average dips him just
below fresh for his fright fest flicks
at 56 percent however when we combine
both filmmakers audience score rankings
john notches the top two with the thing
at 92 percent
and halloween at 89 those are two
all-time greats
and they were both released before wes's
highest ranking audience score favorite
a nightmare on elm street wes craven
pushed john carpenter all the way to the
last house on the left
but it's gonna be john that wins round
two so it's his cul-de-sac
and we're tied at one a piece it's on
the reflexes
round three iconic moments was 20th
century auteur sebastian bach who said
i remember you and when we sing that
tune about horror movies
we're talking about all the moments that
scared the crap out of us
we couldn't sleep for a week yet
inexplicably we keep coming back for
more
carpenter and craven or as i call them
crave arpenter
were experts at that terrifying scenes
that would show us to the bone and
satisfy our expectations
while still keeping us on the edge of
our seat
from the earliest notes of 1978's
halloween we're already feeling tension
partially achieved by carpenter's
pioneering panaglide camera work
which gave us the unique first-person
perspective of michael myers
the babysitter kills in that movie also
gave us another reason
to politely refuse your neighbor's
request to watch their kids
i don't care how much the andersons tip
when they split a bottle of wine at
dinner
it ain't worth it john would go on to
create specific scenarios that creep up
on us and grab
hold of our emotions like the
defibrillator scene from the thing
the car fixing itself and christine and
the elevator scene in big trouble in
little china
okay it's not a horror movie unless you
happen to be in that elevator
it's getting hot in here is it just me
but if it's badass battles you want
carpenter delivered with one of the most
epic fight sequences in history
between roddy piper and keith david in
they live
those fellows were out of bubble gum for
a while because they kicked a
boatload of ass mama don't like
tattletails
a great fight scene a surprising scare
they all add up to thrilling
entertainment
but you got to be able to cash the check
at the climax and for that
i'd advise you to see how perfectly john
carpenter stuck the landing
in in the mouth of madness look i'm not
a voracious reader anyway but if it's a
sutter cane novel
i'm not even listening to that on
audible this is
reality
just as important as giving us a
memorable climax is buckling the
audience up
right from the get-go and no one gets
our hearts racing from 0-60 faster
than wes craven just ask drew barry
moore
but it's not only et's human pal that
gave us shivers
the introduction to the folks under the
steps in the people under the stairs
instantly locks us into the danger
lurking just beneath our toesies
freddie obviously knows how to properly
introduce himself but not just in the
original classic
also wes craven's new nightmare it's a
decent sized build up in this meta world
but under the sheets
ferd is waiting and answer his question
i can't speak for nancy slash heather
but yes
i missed you welcome back your dreams
were your
ticket out ever played in the cat
wes craven was such a master of the
bombastic opening diddy that he played
on our expectations for him as a
filmmaker with screen
four those fake outs are so good
the scream franchise is packed with both
gruesome standout scenes
and craven's wink and nod horror movie
hand-holding
it's like the twilight zone twilight
zone a movie within a movie
i get that but it's illogical it begs
the question that if the beginning of
stab seven is step six then is the
beginning of step six step five and if
so
what is stab four about in the first
scream we're all at a video story
listening to the rules of scary movies
then in scream 2 we hear the sequel
rules but we can't just hand this round
to west craven without some truly brutal
oh right glenn gets sucked into a bed
the camper attack and the hills have
eyes
the intensity of last house on the left
wes craven and john carpenter
can straight up scare us but the edge
here is for craven for his ability to
freak us out after he's hinted to us
exactly how he's going to do it and
number three
never ever ever under any circumstances
say
i'll be right back because she won't be
back if it came down to a basketball
scene
snake pliskin struck first but deadly
friend dunked harder
i don't believe what i just saw no one
made movies for a packed theater of
frady cats more than the late
great wes craven and for that he gets
the win in round three
and he's up two to one there's a formula
to it a very
simple formula everybody's a suspect
and now it's time for the wild card
round best characters
here's some advice for all you novice
horror movie fans out there
don't get too attached to your favorite
character doesn't matter if it's a hero
or a villain their odds are not great on
surviving the movie
take john carpenter for example outside
the cruel world of scary movies
he made heroes we could pull for because
we like them but also because we're
pretty sure they're going to make it out
alive
jack burton snake pliskin and the
non-kurt wrestled
starman which got that dude his first
academy award nomination
i can't get no but within the confines
of horror cinema
the rules are very different just ask
randy one of the many memorable
characters from the scream franchise
jamie kennedy's role serves as the voice
of the audience
he is the cautious shakespearean choir
that wonderful west utilized at wants to
ease our worries
and keep us on our toes would fellow
players of note like gail
dewey and even ghostface abide by the
constraints of the genre
you gotta watch the movie to find out
then the secret rules
do not apply because i'm that kid that
eats the icing with a side of cake
let's not forget all the great albeit
less celebrated roles that wes craven
and john carpenter have blessed their
films with craven's the people under the
stairs had the nutcase mom and dad
and i don't know that ten-year-old mark
rooted harder for any protagonist than i
did for fool
let's also give a shout to jackson
ripper from redeye and
anton arcane from swamp thing i know
you're watching anton
keep mucking it up stevie wayne and john
carpenter's the fog deserves credit
as does someone who isn't necessarily in
a horror movie but is a great villain
in big trouble in little china lopan
george nada and frank armachud from they
live alone could win this round against
most other filmmakers
but speaking of great fights wes and
john are two all-time legends so this
category is going to be one on the
strength
of their greatest creations for john
carpenter that's michael myers and
laurie strode from halloween
so many ingredients went into making
this classic stew
but the recipe doesn't work without the
meat and potatoes of a true heroine and
a truly horrific baddie
what's the boogeyman as a matter of fact
it was if halloween rejuvenated the
slasher genre
michael myers redefined the horror movie
villain
myers paved the way for jason chucky
ghostface the leprechaun virtually every
scary movie antagonist
including freddy krueger yep that weirdo
custodian that all the parents burned
alive before he could chase his dream of
stand-up comedy
is just a more mouthy direct descendant
of hat and field mikey
and while i'm much more afraid of a
killer who can get me in my dreams and
heckle me when i'm on stage
fred is still standing on the shoulder
of the guy who came before him
and after him since we got a new
halloween movie coming next year so
how does freddy feel about that one more
crack at bat
huge propers to heather langenkamp's
nancy who made for an admirable teenager
you could actually root for
in a nightmare in elm street much in the
same way we all instantly knew
we'd always cheer on laurie strode but
wes craven elevated the final girl
archetype to the next level
with nev campbell's sydney prescott
literally spelling out how horror movies
work
for a whole new generation of fans
michael and laurie or freddie and sydney
if all other things are a tie
i tend to go with the trailblazer who
helped start the fire
oh freddy sorry too soon
i'm leaning towards john carpenter in
this round and then pushing me off the
fence entirely is rj mcgrady from the
thing
ladies and gentlemen none of us were
ever worthy of apex kurt russell but
thank goodness he was there
keith david's child's is tremendous as
well but if we needed a real tie breaker
how about the thing that's a character
right
and a good one at that you should see
its impressions look out rich little
john carpenter's army is going to
outlast craven's navy in this round
and now we're tied at two to two
i have come here to chew bubble gum
and kick ass and i'm all out of
bubblegum
well great really done it this time now
it's up to me to render the ultimate
sudden death overtime decision
honestly i'm just thrilled i survived in
this vid this long
thank goodness i didn't lose my
virginity after round two
i got close though we're working you can
never have sex
okay anyway let's consult our expert
researcher mark hoffmeyer
besides having the number three ranked
movie podcast in the netherlands
he's also a wiz when it comes to
combining horror movie statistics
if rotten tomatoes is scream mark
hoffmeyer is
r randy smartmart as the crew calls him
compiled a number of metrics into one
quantifiable integer that can rank the
best movies from john and west
and each director has five movies in the
top ten
halloween was number one but craven had
three of the top five
so i don't know oh i got it who had the
best vampire movie
john carpenter's vampires versus wes
craven's vampire in brooklyn
nah i don't it's a battle of directors
you know ask any filmmaker what's the
secret sauce that helps get a movie into
the bones of the audience
the music and perhaps no land-based
movie has ever had as
instantly recognizable of a score as
halloween
and it was composed and performed by jc
himself
[Music]
so all due respect to the chilling
nightmare and elm street theme
and big ups to west for his perfect use
of alice cooper schools out in scream
and oh i'm getting late word meryl
streep and wes craven teaming up for
music of the heart
what's the matter you got cooties or
something oh
apparently look still it's john
carpenter and his
ivory tickling that gets him to win
today i've actually seen him live in
concert playing his hits and it was
awesome it was on halloween no less the
only way to stay safe for michael myers
is to be in a pack theater with 500 of
them
john carpenter is my pick but i'm just
one dude here
now it's your turn fearless viewer to
cast your vote for the best scary movie
on tour of them all
comment below with your pick and defend
your reason with vigor
i'm gonna read each and every one of
them might even reply to a few right
after i get a drink from the garage
it's okay i'll be right back
[Music]
you